and you're looking at mrs. Holly don't
do I'm chopping trees I've done
something special I don't pay no
attention to what they say about me I've
told you all that I was the greatest of
all time
but my main fight is for freedom and
equality
you really can't plan a fight when you
mean the man you never met before right
I'm gonna dance and be pretty I'm just a
read on or maybe sometimes the wheel can
outdo the skill you are fighting the
greatest fight of all times
this is the Elisha he's an American
former professional boxer he's widely
considered among the greatest
heavyweights in the history of the sport
he's one of the most recognized sports
figures of the past hundred years he's
Muhammad Ali and here his top ten rules
for success I'm thinking it's so
superior and why now it is so positive
and my logic so wise until it clashes
with the mentality which is down here
and I'm both there I'm even so high I
can see more see father knew and you
looking at mrs. Ali don't do it honey
please downright hurt and you want a job
making 60 70 pounds a week all over this
damn never never been out of the country
not known in his own neighborhood Ali
don't do it but I'm in such a high level
until I don't think like you I'm not
like you
I'm not say you a mean on your person
but you Bernard but you know why they
say that I race for the best possible
reasons so they have fear and they are
wearing looks looks dangerous to them
that's right not really the danger to me
a little more than halfway through
irritated and taunted
he was not now clearly with the great
light
no problem this will be the biggest
upset since Sonny Liston and I think it
is befitting that I go out of boxing
just like I came in defeating a big bad
monster that nobody could destroy a hard
punch I'm the underdog if he hits me I'm
in trouble like the Sonny Liston fight
but I came back and I shook the world
and I got listed last ten years since
Sonny Liston I'm eating another big bad
strong monster knockout artist that
beats everybody Sonny Liston knocked out
Patterson twice and I was supposed to
fall but he didn't knock me out because
he could hit hard but he couldn't find
any yet George Foreman knocked out Ken
Norton knocked out Joe Frazier true I
didn't knock him out but I'm so fast I'm
so hard-hit I'm so scientific I'm a
total different man from Frazier Norton
listen David when I meet this man if you
think the world was surprised when Nixon
resigned wait till I whip phones behind
I'm telling you David I'm down to two
hundred and fifteen pounds right now
said it went to 15 I'm fighting weight
already I used to Train six weeks for
fight I've trained for months or so I'm
chopping trees I've done something
special I've wrestled with a alligator
Oh
Tulsa William you totally I believe you
come on out Tulsa what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning throw thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad on the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick
woman people are further George Foreman
they talk about how hard he hits the
world has been deceived you listen to me
I've never told you wrong the man don't
hit hard he knocked Joe Frazier down six
time he got up six times Joe King Roman
is Tokyo Japan fight the Puerto Rican
champion not from down three times he
jumped up three times he knocked in
Norton down four times he jumped up four
times when if he ever saw the man say
seven eight nine ten kanna's man out
when I hit started listen to the sacrum
fight he stayed off the count of ten
Zhora folded stayed off the count of ten
Cleveland Williams stay down for the
count of ten what do I have knocked out
stayed down Sugar Ray Robinson knocked
him out for counter thirty Joe Lewis
Marciano Jack Dempsey Jack Johnson
Archie Moore as a child they knock him
out cold so this man is never not nobody
else cold he's a bully he slow he has no
skill no footwork he's awkward and I
haven't given him a name
I named flora Patterson the rabbit I
named Sonny Liston the bear and he shall
be known as officially as the mummy the
money and why why the mummy because he
fights when he's fighting if you ever
watch him in the ring he he he he drags
like that off his opponent
Emma and has a mummy gonna catch me when
you're fighting a mummy you just keep a
step ahead of the money see you move it
yes just move on my mummy not mummy I'm
over here no mommy oh yeah yeah now are
you moving too fast The Mummy don't move
it
I don't pay no attention to what they
say about me all I do is just do what I
have to do and get paid and that's it
but I don't really pay no attention to
the rules of boxing I don't pay no
attention I defy all the rules that if I
had at pages to the book of boxes I have
this game is such a thing now until
boxing promoters can no longer afford my
shows I have governments like Iran ready
to put up ten million for me to fight
Joe Frazier
I have governments like Cairo Egypt want
to put up six million with people like
Ron Lau I have countries all like all
back throughout zyre talking to my
Bhutto he wants him back again they put
up five more million for retirement
Fullman when we talk about ten million
and six million and four million this is
unbelievable and they don't SPECT to get
the money back they promote in their
countries and the ideals
so I've like sales so in this sport of
boxing until Madison Square Garden is
too small
Yankee Stadium is too small the Houston
Astrodome the biggest promoters in the
wealth is Americans and Englishman's you
can get for promotions cannot just
promote me no more you understand so
I've not only added pages to boxing but
added new sections to blue boxing book
golly
but everybody stop talking now attention
I told you all of my critics I told you
all that I was the greatest of all time
when I beat Sonny Liston I told you
today I'm still the greatest of all time
never again defeat me never again say
that I'm gonna be defeated
never again that make me then the dog
until I'm about 50 years old then you
might get me but I didn't dance I didn't
dance for a reason I wanted to make him
lose all his power I kept telling you
yet no punch he couldn't hit he's
swinging like a [ __ ] he's missing
let me see you box I hadn't started
dancing yet you can't say my legs are
going you can tell was tired because
what happened I didn't dance from the
sock on our own I stayed on the ropes
when I stay on the ropes you think I'm
doing bad but I want to all boxes to put
this on the page of boxes staying on
homes as a beautiful thing
with a heavy weight when you make him
shoot his best shots and you know he's
not hitting you I would've gave George
home with two rounds a steady puncher
because out today he was mine
Ellis's really
he looks defenseless on the road
maybe deciding whether he's going to
stop the party I really cared nothing
about boxing boxing is a stepping stone
just to introduce me to the audience a
like or like like are like if I was
still in Louisville Kentucky it never
was a boxer I might get killed next week
and some type of freedom struggle and
you never read the news but now if I
would even say the wrong thing and make
news
so like boxing is just to introduce me
to the struggle like when I speak I draw
people in the states to draw my people
to teach them various things which are
given dignity pride and self help go for
self I have to get on help the dope
prostitution problem the juveniles and I
use my image to help I'll do all I can
to stop a lot of trouble among the only
people fighting and killing each other
so boxing is just going to be another
year but my main fight is for freedom
and equality and this is what I plan to
do in boxing it's good for livelihood
the mainly money don't really mean that
because I proved that when I gave up the
title not knowing if I'm coming back or
not for four years and they let me back
on my terms I didn't deny nothing I
believe still the same everything so if
even today if my title they hadn't been
giving back to them if I got such an
apology I had to go find a job I
would've did that but I was I made good
living speaking in colleges goes to war
got unpopular and so many black
militants we were trying to do all they
could and I was unnaturally right in the
middle of all of it represented it they
kept me alive but if I couldn't fight I
would still not be fighting so number
one comes freedom first of my people
equality and this is what I plan to do
after I'm through fighting working with
nothing but the people the little people
in Allen's the wine here and down try to
people going out among them and helping
them well with my image
Oh
you know I'm sure Henry Italian and Fido
and the knows what's happening
you really can't plan to fight when you
meet the man you never met before right
you just have to get your tools ready
here's a car stops on the highway they
call a triple-a or whatever and said my
car's broke down what is it lady she
don't notice me well the man comes with
all the tools and he come equipped to
handle whatever the problem is astronaut
goes into space and he pretends that
something happens to the ship before he
take off he gets out and he works on it
he's not looking for something happen
but it might happen so I didn't I just
had everything ready now after the first
round being here with a top professional
a man so great had sold me the Knockouts
never been defeated never even scratched
I didn't know really how good he was so
I had to come in actually a little
nervous and with everything ready after
one round of deaths and I found out that
this would tide me out so I would have
to resort the ropes I figured that out
after the first round so I said I'm
gonna go to these ropes and I'm let this
man through everything he can't let
ourself out it might look like he's
winning
if you don't hurt me imma stay here but
if he should be as great as they say he
is if he hits as hard as they say he hit
when he hit your brakes you are me
knocked out Joe Frazier I couldn't do it
knock on Ken Don he was a big bad job
before the fight you remember and they
remember that don't you yeah good bet it
was they don't say that never he was a
real bad catch of the day right don't
forget that now after I found out he
didn't have it I stayed there but if he
had had what I thought he had had what
they said he's here I'd have kept
running hoping I wouldn't get tired
it's really silly when you think about
fighting I look at other fighters
fighting us I must be a fool here are
two men like two roosters you know them
[ __ ] fights they take two roosters and
they put them out and they put knives on
them in the Roosters of fighting each
other and they're not even mad don't
know each other and just to please
somebody I hear two men in the ring
fighting each other and they hitting
each other
tonic bleeding and fighting what they
mad about they're not mad about nothing
just took just a bunch a eight eight and
blood those two people saying you can
whip him he can whip in my mag and whip
your man all right y'all get in and
fight you must have more sense me and
you said not that dressed up drinking
your beer but they just fight me just ah
they're just getting and this is serious
the nose bleeding the eyes cut teeth is
out and the brain they might have a
concussion just to please you human
beings is real Savage and I said I'm not
gonna be that kind of fight I'm gonna
dance and be pretty I'm just gonna win
on point and if I hurt my man I'm gonna
let him go I'm not going to kill him
just because somebody's watching I did
it to Floyd Patterson I did it to George
evallo I did it to call miltenberger I
did two hitting the coupe when he start
bleeding like a pulled off her
deliberately blood just pumping and
gushing and he's got a family he's got
children and I just came James Ellis I
can't see myself with a man on the ropes
and just to prove how bad I am and I see
I got in his eyes in his head he's
helpless and I'm just literally hitting
him I don't do that
in the fight
Oh
what is the world champion boxer
basketball player track star harshly
manimals I find out that this Mark Spitz
for example he's a world champion but
what made him the world champion was
that he seemed to at the right time when
the pressures down at the last few yards
he can get that lead he's got enough
left a million I found Ken Norton my
last fight the fight was even up in the
last round but I had something that he
didn't have all our much older that was
the last minute kick what's that last
minute kick is that sometimes the
stamina the strength but more than
training the mental capacity mental
group to realize what's involved and how
important it is and make it by to do
something is really too tired to do your
mind makes you do it
Mark Spitz this Olympic track star was
mentioning he wasn't that much greater
than all the people in the world was
some time he won by just that much and
this other champion is just one who can
come out at the last minute the closes
show us and say the star closes show a
1415 round fight and this even and that
usually this champion you can depend on
him to come to the last few seconds and
find some invincible source it's a
discipline not only that is mental and
physical give his body's in physical
shape to do it plus mentally - he's got
a self in condition where both fellas
maybe sometimes the wheel can outdo the
skill sometime a fellow's wheel is
stronger than the man who is actually
better physically and the determination
and weakens the other man just to see
him so determined
you're pre-fight your pre-flight to
build up some when you go to the
weigh-in you have oh they appear mock up
battles with the other opponent are they
really how much is that is towards the
under my shadow trying to fight there
because I wouldn't be paid but I really
do be angry I have to psych myself up I
put myself on spots I'll say it just
took fresh Island for the build for the
best sort of well I not really because
evening the fight that's when that
happens and it's really sold out by the
end but it actually puts fear in your
opponent like George Foreman just before
the fight I'm looking at him in the
man's ear as instructions I said sucker
you are in trouble tonight you are
fighting the greatest fight of all times
you heard I was the greatest like you
just said you heard this name you see it
I said you said I was the greatest but
you're gonna see I'm fast sucker I'm
gonna burn you up you fighting you idol
when you a little kid you heard about me
you know and he was he wouldn't fight he
didn't have his first fight in 1969 I've
been in exile two years after all I'm
done he just started fighting so when I
was fighting people like you in the
sixties he was just located in junior
high school I said you're meeting your
master your idol he looked at me then I
went back first round I laid in the
corners right I said come on show me
something I talked through the whole
fight I love you all know it I talked
through the whole fight I should come on
sucker
I said show me something they told me
you could hit hard
you're just a [ __ ] come on you can do
better than that George look you wanna
karna me who I am you're waiting economy
he just knew it everyone small iscope
see the quickest way to a point is a
straight line to hit me here to do that
oh and why he's doing that
how's it attacking her jabs right
pop-pop your fighter you know every meet
a man coming into like that don't worry
about it don't duck like it's so
powerful just pop him pop see see he's
going out hit him
he's sticking warning oh I grabbed his
head sometimes that's it
look at you look at you round seven and
you're tired you have eight more rounds
to go
come on keep punching I want you to get
tired I said uh-uh
I said this is the wrong place to get
tired this is the wrong place to get
tired he's just throwing him I said then
he got a couple of bruises she knows his
face is kind of folder I said look
engine you're the World Heavyweight
Champion
you're the world rottens hitman you're
the world heavyweight champion and look
at me
you can't hit is it Roger come another
pop us a little bit really he threw the
I said come on come on get I'm going
back the rope now I laid back that's
okay take your best shot
can you finish out his breathing us all
oh you finished boy you in trouble I
said you don't have but two chances slim
and none
you in trouble I talked them to the
whole fight
I was told that it's a big honor to be
invited to speak in a place like Harvard
I'm trying to be serious but you want to
make me laugh anyway
I understand that out of people such as
you all come presidents and governors
mayors and great doctors and physicians
and scientists and everything so I said
well to get something together to talk
to these people it's got to be pretty
heavy
if you had told me I'd be offered a
professorship to teach philosophy and
portrait Oxford and speaking it Harvard
man I never believed it so I'm real
humble and I'm thankful to be here it's
such a high seed of learning and I'm
just a box of the most boxes game talk
you couldn't invite Joe Frazier George
Foreman
this is the Alicia
in the law in glorious history of
Harvard University
no speaker ever received such a
tumultuous standing ovation
thank you
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Lex venden Herrick
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you aren't made of
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Muhammad
Ali's top ten rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments and I'll
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
if you ever get frightened before a
fight you're getting nerves for nervous
we're not frightened I've been I'm
nervous because I have a great insight
on I just don't see the audience on
every camera
I see millions of people like the Fraser
fight was watched by ten hundred million
people which is five times the
population of everybody in the United
States just a picture Reena with 1
million people I met you couldn't see
them all
and just think about 100 million and ten
hundred million and all those people and
everything that makes me nervous it's
the idea of me just met on a humble
fellow from Kentucky got lucky in sports
and now here's the house a fight was
piped in the place like Thailand to the
government house and Arabia and the
government officials took time off to
watch the fight and just for two men
boxing attracting so many people of all
races and nationalities and how ye
understand they they stopped closed all
the factories and the people they set
televisions on every street corner
people came out watching the fight on
the streets and every bar in America
every every Houston traffic was still
doing that fight in Madison Square
Garden 10,000 people couldn't get in and
just over one man and just imagine all
them people watching you that makes me
nervous until target started and then no
one else to do no how about this villain
role you're going to be the villain and
let's listen is getting to be listen was
the villain didn't know about it like
listen listen the thug Liston was a
gangster listen was just drifting who's
that everybody will see mr. Beach so now
all of a sudden listen is the Frazier
you know I guess whether I like it that
makes me a rumble Rumble blow like a
butterfly sting like a bee
are we gonna do that we gonna run oh
well I have a point huh one minute one
goes like this people say what's gonna
happen you meet Joe Frazier again here's
how the fight sound on the radio for
those who can't afford to buy the
expensive theater seats and the fight
goes like this Dean Ali comes out to
meet Frazier but Frazier starts to
retreat if Frazier goes back an inch
father you'll wind up in a ringside seat
all these swings are left all these
swings are the right look at the kid
carry the fight Frazier keeps backing
but there's not enough room it's a
matter of time there Ali lowers the boom
now Ali lands on the right
what a beautiful swing and the pulseless
Frazier cleaned out of the rain
Frasier's the horizon but the referee
was a frown for he can start counting
until Frasier comes back now Frasier
disappears from view the crowd is
getting frantic but our radar stations
have picked him up he someone's over the
Atlantic who would have thought when
they came to the fight that they would
have witnessed the luncheon of a colored
satellite